well there certainly is a lot of
political news Donald Trump has been
indicted on 37 counts it's insane
including Espionage charges I think we
have uh we have that story but we do
have a very big culture War Story ladies
and Gentlemen The Gamers have joined the
culture War I guess because technically
they started it but they're back I guess
it's younger generation of Gamers this
is this is this is big news as far as
I'm concerned Call of Duty has pulled
Activision has pulled a streamer named
Nick marks who has millions of
subscribers because he tweeted leave the
little kids alone
he said he stands by what he he stands
by what he said he appreciates everybody
who has his back they pulled him and
said yeah well we're going to remove
your stuff because we celebrate
celebrate Pride here then another very
big streamer Dr disrespect came out and
said no dice sided with Nick marks what
we are seeing here while it may have
always been Gamers who are very much
opposed to the creepy woke stuff we are
seeing now high profile personalities
join in call for boycotts of these
companies and these games outright on
live streams to massive waves of younger
people because regular people are rising
up and they're saying no more to this so
when you get a guy and you know what
they're saying they're saying that Nick
Merk's dad instincts kicked in because
he said he just had a kid and then all
of a sudden it's like now he gets it
this is what's starting to happen as the
younger people are getting a little bit
older and they're realizing what woke
people are doing in their name they're
starting to say no so not only are we
seeing this major move in terms of a
call for a boycott on a Major Video Game
target has reportedly lost 15 billion
billion dollars off their market cap now
we've got CNN and the likes of other
companies uh other media Outlets saying
no no it's nothing to do with the
boycott despite the fact that Walmart
isn't suffering their stock seems to be
just fine so we're going to talk about
this and more and obviously we'll talk a
bit about the political stuff it's a
Friday night before we get started my
friends head over to castbrew.com and
help fight the commies by buying cast
Brew Coffee how does it help fight
commies it's it's our coffee company so
basically when you buy this coffee you
are supporting people who don't hate you
and who want to help have a positive
impact on culture make more coffee make
more coffee shops and just grow a
company that exists outside of the woke
corporate structures so let's build that
parallel economy at casper.com don't
forget to also go to timcast.com join
the fight directly by clicking join us
and becoming a member to get access to
our massive library of uncensored
members only shows we do those Monday
through Thursday at 10 pm so go to
timcast.com join us smash the like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends joining us
tonight to talk about this and a whole
lot more is Riley Moore hey Tim thanks
for having me back on this is awesome
absolutely who are you on the state
treasurer West Virginia I'm also the
Congressional candidate for the second
congressional district in West Virginia
right on good to have you back yeah
thanks a lot Ali who's hanging out again
hey what's up everybody Riley Thanks so
much for coming on we have I'm sure a
great show planned with you my name is
alad aliyahu I'm a reporter here at
timcast news check out my work and other
journalists who work here's work at at
Twitter on Twitter at timcast news
hello everybody I am Phil Labonte lead
singer of All That Remains
anti-communist and counter-revolutionary
and I'm Ian Crossland number four uh I
was on the culture War today if you guys
haven't seen that yet with Zach Voorhees
it was epic Tim Zack and I talked about
AI for like two hours it got crazier and
crazier as the conversation went on
highly recommend checking that out on
YouTube at uh Tim pools the culture War
it was very fun youtube.com timcast
there it is
and uh to my right this beautiful mess
hey what's up uh my name is Kellen I see
a lot of times people like hey who is
this who's this fake surge well I work
behind the scenes most of the week uh
but on Fridays I do live switching
thanks sir you know uh whatever they
want no they've got all kinds of
nicknames but yeah so that's me that's
good to be hanging out with you guys
yeah let's jump into this first story
from ign.com Activision polls FaZe Clan
streamer Nick Merk's skin from Call of
Duty following
anti-lgbtq plus tweet quote we are
focused on celebrating Pride with our
employees and our community so first who
is this guy FaZe uh I believe I have his
YouTube right here he's a streamer plays
video games he's got four million
subscribers and what exactly did he say
that got his skin pulled from this game
he said they should leave little
children alone that's the real issue
leave them kids alone so uh there's a
great and powerful Revelation in this
tweet and what's happening
in response Activision tweeted this a
Call of Duty on Twitter which is an
Activision game Charlie Intel says it
appears Activision has removed the Nick
Merks bundle from the war zone and
Modern Warfare 2 store this evening
Activision has not commented on why it
has been removed but the removal of his
bundle comes a day after nickmark's
recent comments about the LGBT plus
Community Call of Duty says due to
recent events we have removed the Nick
Mark's operator bundle from the Modern
Warfare 2 and Warzone store we are
focused on celebrating Pride with our
employees and our community
is actually pretty amazing let me get
right to it
Nick Merks did not say anything
anti-lgbtq
he said they should leave little
children alone that's the real issue
let's break this down let's dissect what
this uh prominent streamer with millions
of followers on Twitter and millions on
YouTube said leave kids alone
if a leftist showed up to a school where
they were protesting
uh parents were protesting these books
an antifa person said leave the kids
alone
is that anti or pro-lgbtq it's very
vague if a leftist said leave kids alone
they would assume it was a leftist
statement and say the right is targeting
kids
Nick Nick marks didn't say anything
specific other than leave kids alone it
could have been left or right wing so
there's something else you can see here
the fact that simply by saying leave
kids alone
the left got triggered angry and pulled
him from this game shows they actually
understand that they are targeting
children with something negative well
what is this it's a response what's it
in response to
so this Pucket account says this
happened four blocks from my OverWatch
League apartment Americans are in a sad
place right now let people love who they
love and live your own life and it was
in response to the video of the parents
fighting with uh with far left as
activists you can see the sign here
protect trans kids
he says they should leave a little
children alone that's the real issue now
hold on
why is it that the immediate assumption
was that this was a right wing or
anti-lgbtq post
I mean the sign in the video says
protect trans kids wouldn't his
statement be in agreement with what that
sign says protect the kids yeah they
should leave those kids alone yeah I
mean they've totally exposed themselves
on this right and the funny thing is
the hypocritical thing is this is
supposed to be like the party of choice
and that's really what this battle is
about is that parents want to be able to
have the choice to have their kids opt
out of the pride month educational
program that they have mandated every
child has to go through now a long time
ago uh when I was in school you could
opt in or opt out of sex education now
I'm sure as it relates to heterosexual
uh education I'm sure that's still the
case but apparently in pride month
there's no opt out like these are the
guys of choice right well no they're not
actually this is about compulsion it's
about control and I think it's about
brainwashing the young people in this
country yes I got that I saw a video of
them dancing through the hallways of
elementary school like the little kids
and they're like a rainbow they were
like dancing through a rainbow portal or
something I saw that I thought about it
when I was six and seven in like first
and second grade and like what I would
have felt going into that would have
been very afraid like not and I maybe
that sounds crude but like I don't just
like I I it would have made me nervous
because I didn't know what it was and
everyone's screaming but like they wanna
it's a chance to not have to do boring
schoolwork so everyone's in for a lot of
people are into it but like I can see
how kids would be like not comfortable
but not saying anything about it because
when you're seven what the hell can you
say and who can you say it to well and
this is just one event that's happening
in the Unified School District of Los
Angeles they've now instituted I think
it's like five separate days of you know
uh trans awareness and a Day of Silence
and another pride month and this and
this and that if these people celebrated
like the Fourth of July maybe perhaps
like they celebrated this we'd have a
very different country right I mean it's
insane let me let me show you this Nick
Merks responded to the backlash saying
friends are created in good times but
families are built through adversity
appreciate all of you that have my back
understand my position as a new father
and recognize the love I have for all
ain't no Hate In This Heart pnl
I mean that's it I mean it's very well
set look back down I have three kids
right and no one is in control of my
kids except me and my wife that's it
they want control over everyone's kids I
mean we've seen that debate happen over
and over again they want to have the
control of shaping our child's uh uh
future yes their thoughts what they're
going how they view the world that's me
I am in control of them I am their
parent not these teachers not these
activists me and my wife the left is
motivated to affect the what they call
cultural hegemony so when you have kids
and you send them to what you assume are
schools that are going to teach them how
to be good Americans how to be liberals
how to be you know uh live in our
society
when you do that you make more
capitalists that's what schools used to
do nowadays the well and what happened
was the left realized that to to break
that reproduction of the society is the
only way that you're gonna get to a
socialist United States so they go into
the schools using a free airing method
and they break that hegemony by teaching
children
their morals and their uh you know moral
the way that they want Society to be
what's the free Aryan method Palo free
area was a was a
uh Portuguese uh Marxist and he is is
the most influential in current schools
um basically he wants to have generative
issues so the way that he wants to her
the way that his method is teach
children in a way that introduces
political themes to them right so if
you're teaching math
the freyrian method figures out a way to
not only teach the math lesson or teach
the math lesson and additionally teach
the political aspects or teach political
aspects like how many stars are on the
flag how many stripes are on the flag
yeah stuff like that but um so they
would maybe they're talking about uh you
know maybe they're talking about how
much it costs to get into maybe they're
talking about about money right or
talking about you know using using money
as a as a as an example
um they would try to direct the
conversation and this is just an example
this is not like this is not the
directed way but they would you they
would try to say well maybe you're going
to get everyone in the car and go to the
amusement park well there's a bunch of
ways that you can make that political
first of all you could talk about the
car well does everyone get into everyone
gets in the car but is that really good
for the environment are you going how
many people are going in the car is it
is it bad for the environment to go to
the amusement park who's been to an
amusement park everybody's been you
haven't been to amusement park how come
you haven't been to an amusement park
well you know your parents don't have
the money these are all ways that you
can bring up politics in what is
ostensibly a math or a geography or
whatever lesson and if you can teach
kids if you can bring up politics they
call it a generative issue it can
generate questions that's all the LGBT
stuff is when you have kids in front of
a drag queen kids are going to ask
questions why is that person dressed
like that and then you can start talking
about
LGBT issues exactly that's exactly what
it is that's why it's called group
because it makes it normative yes
exactly it gives it gives politically
motivated people an opportunity to bring
up leftist talking points and leftist
politics well and to that point though
part of this is as human beings we have
what's called observable reality right
so to Phil's point
I could say Phil
I'm colorblind but that wall looks green
to me phil'd say well I can see with my
vision that is a gray wall Tim say
that's a gray wall as Society we can say
objectively in reality that's a gray
wall
but my perceived reality it's green so
we're having to accept everyone's
perceived reality
I view you know if somebody says I view
myself as a woman and we're all looking
at that person saying uh no
objective reality says no you're not
observable reality says you're not but
we are now having to upset except their
perceived reality do you know where
that's a problem North Korea
they are controlling what is
objective and observed reality right
they are able to control what is reality
and control language that is where we
are headed on this that's what's
Happening Here
and it starts in the schools
it's all it's all grooming in a variety
of ways but but there is overt targeting
of kids with sexual sexual grooming but
there's also ideological grooming and it
all follows exactly what you said
generative issues
I know I know I explained it a lot but
just for the sake of context for anybody
who hasn't heard I'll give you a very
simple version
modeling
they say do you want to be a model
modeling is a normal job lots of people
model their famous models the groomers
who who use modeling to groom kids will
say you're a model it's normal everyone
does it then they'll say why don't you
wear this bathing suit then they'll say
why don't you take this piece of
clothing off they're slowly inching you
towards something sexual if you want if
if you want to make the claim that
you're just trying to educate kids it
would not start with books that teach
the kids how to use gay dating apps and
that's what they're doing there's a book
called this is gay for those of you that
don't know a teacher in Illinois gave it
to middle schoolers with it within in
the book there's instructions on how to
use adult anonymous gay hookup apps like
that that that is beyond just the the
intro level grooming like she's out
right now instructing them on these
behaviors well and to your point on the
introduction Target right where you had
this huge protest over Target they're
introducing bathing suits generative
issues right yeah they're introducing
bathing suits where kids can tuck right
and they were adults bathing suit yeah
adult bathing suits but I mean it's in a
place where a family shop right and then
the kid's gonna say Dad what's tucking
yeah what's talking they're gonna say
what's Pride you know young kids that
that don't you know the first first time
that they're cognizant and aware and be
like Daddy what's Pride Mommy what's
Pride right off the bat the whole month
of June has become a generative issue
and if you don't want your kids to be
exposed to that stuff at four five right
six now you're called a bigot yes it's
unacceptable every all the schools are
doing it yeah it's unacceptable I think
conservatives moderates anybody who's
anti-work needs to sue the schools to
get the flags removed 100 yes and just
say there it's a political flag it is
offensive to a lot of people that's just
reality you should not have offensive
things and if the courts deem that you
can't have it then start flying the flag
you want to then so there's that there's
that issue in Massachusetts where a kid
worship said there are two genders they
told them take it off can't wear that
shirt yeah
sued over it the judge said until the
until we have a resolution you still
can't wear that shirt and my response is
okay well then they shouldn't fly the
pride Flags if saying there are two
genders is offensive to some the pride
flag which appropriates God's covenant
the rainbow should be offensive to
Christians and that's a protected class
as well religious belief therefore it
should all go if you can't have one you
can't have the other and that goes back
to that observable reality of two
genders like when children are born that
gender is not determined at Birth it is
observed
I want to jump to this next story from
comicbook.com because the boycotts are
getting crazier doctor disrespect
boycott's Call of Duty following Nick
Mark's controversy they say following
the uh Call of Duty has enjoyed an
absurd level of success blah blah blah
last night Nick Mark's skin was removed
from the game etc etc we know this
doctor disrespect uninstalled Call of
Duty and said he won't return until they
apologize or add Nick Merk's operator
bundled back into the game for those
that are just tuning in
Nick marks a prominent streamer with I
think like eight million follows no he's
got more than he's got six million on
Twitch he's got four million on YouTube
he's got 2 million on Twitter said leave
the little children alone that's it so
they ax him from the game now you've got
this guy Dr disrespect who's extremely
also with millions of followers saying I
won't play the game until they apologize
what we are seeing is a major shift I
don't know if Bud Light has anything to
do with it but I wonder
if after everyone saw a 30 sales drop
from Bud Light for doing this two things
happened people became less afraid
thinking hey you know what if I speak
out I can clearly see most people are on
my side and the other thing was
opportunists thought it was popular and
they jumped on board well also real
quick just now you have more prominent
high profile people willing to boycott
powerful Brands over going in this
direction yeah the blood light Fiasco
and boycott and success of the boycott
globally showed people globally that you
have control with social media of
markets and now they're emboldened and
are willing to twist the market at will
uh it can go bad as well I mean it can
go in any direction depending on what
side you're on I've always been
concerned about people like organizing
um a mass withdrawal of money from a
bank on a day when trying to crash the
economy Bradley I wanted to ask you on
this I know you talk a lot about ESG you
mentioned Target and what's going on
with Activision now could you explain to
us what ESG is and does that play into
any of this at all yeah ESG does play
into this actually so Anheuser-Busch
right uh guess who one of the largest
shareholders are van heuser-busch inbev
black BlackRock BlackRock
BlackRock is and Vanguard and so what
since they are some of the largest
shareholders through the dollars that
they manage in retirement funds and
everything else they have massive
amounts of voting power there and so
what they do is push initiatives like
this at board meetings because they've
been able to install their board of
directors on those corporate Boards of
governance and that's how we get here
and that's how decisions like this get
made in simple terms what is ESG for
people who don't understand plain
language and how does it affect this so
very short and quick ESG which stands
for environmental social governance what
it is doing it's forcing dollars towards
ideas instead of returns which is the
opposite of the free market dollars
should flow towards returns not ideas
and what they are doing is coercing
Capital towards ideas instead of returns
and which is going to ultimately I think
destroy the free market in this country
you know Vanguard State Street in
BlackRock I noticed with almost every
public company we talk about has about
22 percent the three companies combined
BlackRock Vanguard State Street have
about 22 of all these public companies
22 22 of Microsoft of apple and it's
they never really have that much more
they never really have that much less so
with 22 what kind of board power can you
access well I mean think about what is
Elon know of Twitter right I mean isn't
like 13 something like that like
controlling interest or something but I
mean when he uh ended up buying it uh I
think the amount of stock that it took
to get there so right he owns it
entirely he owns it entirely now but the
amount of uh so 13 couldn't get him what
he wanted right so he had to buy it out
yeah he had to buy it out and but that
amount of uh leverage that they have
like each one owning 22 22. each one
owns about seven percent yeah yeah seven
percent but these guys in totality cast
of every vote cast on every publicly
traded comp company in the country and
the asset Center management that they
have is larger than the GDP of the
United States in a given year so it's
it's not just about voting though voting
voting with 25 power doesn't sound like
a whole lot the bigger the bigger issue
is if they went to they have seven
percent of insert company and they go
and they say we're holding about 250
million dollars of your company
if you don't do this I'm sorry we're
going to have to protect our clients by
selling off all of this stock which will
cause a panic and a dump on your company
and they're all three coordinated in
their approach I mean 22 look I mean is
a substantial amount of control given I
mean depending on the publicly traded
company that you're talking about
and it gives them a tremendous amount of
Leverage Exxon Mobil was a great example
uh BlackRock was certainly not a
majority stakeholder there but through
working through proxies who they were
able to put onto the board activist
members in 2021 they were able to put
board members on there coordinating with
their other uh ESG woke capitalist uh
buddies they put activist board members
on there that moved and were successful
in reducing oil production at Exxon
Mobil by 20 and increasing green energy
production by 20 which then I guess we
could have used that oil production
right about now right with gas prices so
can you uh it was three companies right
three firms yes State Street Vanguard
BlackRock okay so who owns BlackRock uh
well BlackRock is publicly traded right
right so who's got the who's got the
largest stake in those come and let's
say black rock well yeah I mean Larry
Finks who like the like the one of the
top guys well you want to know who the
yeah those are yeah first we have the
Vanguard group yeah next we have State
Street Corp yeah then we have Bank of
America and there's a list of others the
buy I just highlight this because they
own each other yeah and Larry himself
owns a significant amount in in there as
well who's the CEO of it is yes but they
all do own each other and so there is
you know and look if I'm elected to
congress these guys got to get in my
view they need to get broken up yeah for
sure I'm looking at BlackRock Inc in its
own five percent of it's owned by
BlackRock fund advisors yes Riley for a
moment I wanted to follow up on this ESG
stuff and um kind of play The Devil's
Advocates role because a lot of people
are pushing for this many people are
saying that free markets aren't working
for everybody across our countries now
nowadays and we need to start worrying
about the stakeholders I.E employees or
workers more than just the shareholders
like where the capital is coming from
how would you respond to somebody who's
saying this is really about helping
workers yes stakeholder capitalism is
fake that is not a real thing
stakeholder capitalism so when we in in
West Virginia India we did a restricted
financial institution list for companies
that were boycotting the fossil fuel
industry and I spoke to a lot of the
biggest financial institutions in the
country
and the end of the day a publicly traded
company their job is to maximize
shareholder value right and when I
talked to them I said uh well what what
stakeholder capitalism to you and
they're like well you know people that
have different interests we have uh you
know communities of color indigenous
people we have green energy we have
environmentalists and this and that I
said well what about the shareholder
where they fit into they're like well
they're one of the stakeholders let me
just kind of real real quick go just one
second to insert this pull this up
according to Yahoo finance the top
institutional stakeholder of Vanguard is
Blackrock it is you are right crazy it
should be broken up yeah anyway anyway
the follow-up was going to be that like
often times that because it's uh this is
what people would argue that when it's
just the shareholders in charge some
companies get gutted out and it doesn't
help the workers and some people are
just looking to benefit on the back end
stock side Finance side of it so that
that's kind of yeah the sharehold
older shareholder capitalism I mean is
not helping the employees sure so
exactly the stakeholder capitalism the
idea of it is supposedly although the
devil's in the details and it does
I misspoke there so in in terms of
shareholders some of these guys do get
some type of stock option and blah blah
blah and some of this the share or the
um stakeholder stakeholder version of
that it's not helping the employees
either I mean this didn't help me like
so at Exxon mobil's board it's not a
bunch of employees that said like we
want to reduce oil production so we're
working less no this was pushed by
BlackRock and then engine one which was
a former employee of BlackRock who
started their own company and were able
to uh get onto that board to help
facilitate bringing these uh leftists
onto the board to try to destroy Exxon
Mobil from the inside out
um I mean all this does is essentially
redefine and this is where it gets
slippery and this is by Design what risk
is right what risk is what how do you
define risk well they Define Risk by not
being diverse enough they Define Risk by
uh global climate change what they need
to Define risk is by the very simple uh
definitions what are called pecuniary
factors of material Financial Risk and
return they're going to end up
destroying people's retirement funds I
guess I think the idea here is that
they're arguing that their version of
stakeholder capitalism is going to work
to employ is going to work to help the
average employee I believe free markets
actually help the workers more than what
they're saying with stakeholder capital
and ESG I just want to understand you
don't think this is actually helping the
workers then yeah this isn't helping the
workers at all because that's what
they're arguing that this is for them no
because you have Larry Fink at the top
of this thing right you know over there
BlackRock they all own each other and
they're all in coordination do you think
anybody in these publicly traded
companies have any Vote or any say in
this top down Larry Fink has made very
clear he was of course at the world
economic Forum just recently uh talking
to Aaron Sorkin and saying we are going
to force behaviors we're going to force
behaviors that is what we are going to
do we're going to enforce behaviors and
he has said
capitalism in his view this shareholder
cap stakeholder capitalism has the
ability
to um has the ability to essentially
control people's behavior right has the
ability to shape the world is what he
said essentially I got a correction that
that last I showed wasn't Vanguard it
was a different company called American
Vanguard and they're they they're
confusing and it's actually very
difficult to find who are the largest
shareholders of Vanguard which is
different but I will I will pull it up
so Larry Fink says it has the ability to
shape Society but what if we don't want
the same shape of society that Larry
Fink does I want to interact I want to
interject on that the idea that we
should be shaping Society every time
that's been tried in human history it's
ended with piles and piles of dead
bodies yes when they TR like if you
listen to to Marx he talked about new
socialist man that normal that the man
that man is not ready for the Socialist
uh sister system you have to remake man
Nietzsche did the same thing when he
talked about the Uber the Uber mensch
the over man he believed that without
God man had to come up with his own new
morality and normal man us would not
understand
the over man's morality and the over man
isn't in any position or isn't obligated
to explain to us what they're trying to
do is nothing new like the idea that we
can reshape the world to prevent climate
change which I I mean there's a lot of
things that I have problems that I have
with the arguments for climate change
um but
the effort to remake Humanity always
ends with piles of dead bodies the Nazis
did it the Communists did it more than
once Pol Pot two million people died in
Cambodia that was 20 of all of the
people in Cambodia there was eight
million people in Cambodia before Pol
Pot they killed two million people Mao
tried to change Mal believe that the
sparrows were caught were were a problem
and they weren't communist so they were
trying they were eating the seed and so
he told all the people in China Kill The
Sparrows Don't Let The Sparrows land and
what happened was because the sparrows
were not there to eat the bugs the bugs
ate all the crops and there was a famine
and millions of people died when you try
to affect the whole world when you try
to change mankind humans always screw it
up and it always ends in piles and piles
and piles of dead bodies this ESG stuff
is aimed at affecting climate change you
talk about the stuff that was going on
in not I think it was the Dutch Farmers
that were having the problem that's
because they wanted to they wanted to
limit how much they could produce they
want to limit how much you can use
fossil fuels all of our fertilizer is
fossil fuel base it's all petrochemicals
if you don't have fertilizers then
you're gonna have famines millions and
million if if they're successful with
the to in getting control of basically
the markets Global markets there will be
millions and millions and millions and
millions of people probably a billion
people that will die of famine this is
not hyperbolic either all you have to do
is look at the 19th or at the look at
the the 20th century and see the death
tolls that have CA that were that were a
result of governments trying to reshape
human nature um I wanna real quick just
uh there's no shareholders of Vanguard
Vanguard says they're they're the only
investment management company owned by
its investors
basically means the people who put their
money in it they're quote unquote the
owners but it's someone still runs it
right it and the Phil's point on you
know if listening audience is curious
Nietzsche good luck at Will To Power
that's a book that he wrote yeah it's a
terrible book but uh but it look it's
it's very interesting because that is
kind of where we are right now but to
his point in Ireland they're telling
them that they're going to have to call
that means kill all of their cattle yeah
to reduce uh greenhouse gas emissions
from cows I mean this is how they've
lived there for centuries for centuries
right I mean so what is that going to do
to the island of Ireland the Republic of
Ireland right and the end of the day we
have this collusion as it relates to ESG
in between corporate power and left-wing
ideology so it's this Unholy merger of
corporate power and left-wing ideology
that you've seen before
we got this from The Daily Mail targets
market cap slumps by 15 billion amid
backlash over tuck friendly swimsuits
analysts say retail giant is
hemorrhaging customers to Walmart oh now
all that stuff we're talking about I'm
just gonna sit back and say we're
winning yes yeah you hate to see it oh
no yeah we'll go see it regular people
we saw we saw parents rising up saying
get this stuff away from my kids we're
seeing Gamers who have long been in the
culture where in fact Gamers started the
culture War back with gamergate now
still being very active and now taking
Center Stage once again and now we have
the Bud Light effect Target Kohl's North
Face these companies are getting slammed
by people who are just saying I'm fed up
when did the uh Target boycott begin
middle of May it was on May 21st when
things just started to plummet and uh
yeah May 17th or something two and a
half weeks ago wow
people are just tired of it yeah and the
great thing is is that right now the
free market does still work right we're
watching that we're watching that as it
relates to Target but in a not too
distant future if we don't continue to
push back against this and look I think
we are starting to chip away at this ESG
issue we are now Vanguard has dropped
out of the Net Zero uh asset managers
Alliance now I think they're still doing
it they're still involved in it but
they're starting to hedge you're seeing
people start to hatch
um and these folks are going to have to
learn their lesson in free market
economics guess who shops at Target uh
not your uh woke liberal Elites they're
driving Subarus to Whole Foods right so
Riley so I wanted to follow up with you
you're running for a very important in
the second congressional district here
in West Virginia I know um ESG has been
a big part of your campaign so far are
there any other big issues that you're
especially concerned about yeah
certainly obviously we've done a lot in
the state treasurer's office which I'm
in currently on ESG but some of the
other big ones is China's something that
we're going to have to contend with as a
country and moving forward I mean the
idea that we're still making
Pharmaceuticals over there I think is
hugely problematic they're going to be
one of the biggest uh one of the biggest
threats I think in the near and
long-term future for us but domestically
where I'm focused and I run what's
called The Hope Scholarship here in West
Virginia it's an educational savings
account we must and underline this we
must eliminate the Department of
Education it has to go wow it has to go
big Proclamation right there no the
Department of Education must be
eliminated if you look at when Jimmy
Carter instituted that to where we are
now we used to be number one in
education in the world and where we are
now
it is not working and so we need to move
that money back to the States and then
take a portion of that money to create
educational savings accounts all around
the country because not as many states
are as free as West Virginia but every
American child whether in California or
New York needs to have educational
opportunity and choice so that's going
to be a big issue as well I wanted to
follow up with you there's a very
contentious Republican presidential
primary going on I'm not sure if you
heard what do you think of the primaries
so far I have heard I've heard a little
bit about that I have endorsed uh
president Trump and so that is certainly
who I'm supporting can I follow up with
you on that I talked a lot about this I
talked about it with Sheamus yesterday I
see that you were endorsed by the West
Virginia for Life yes in a lot of
Trump's statements he actually sounds
less pro-life than Ron DeSantis does I
think Ron DeSantis was trying to push
six weeks bands while Trump puts out
tweets blaming um the abortion issue for
Trump for Republicans losing in the
midterms so how do you square you know
supporting endorsing Trump and being so
pro-life when there are other more
pro-life people in the field yeah you
know I've seen some of those statements
I can't say I'm necessarily happy with
that in West Virginia we passed a ban
and it's zero weeks uh in West Virginia
so obviously when was that uh that was
in the last session it passed this
January yeah so that's Virginia always
gets ignored when these things happen
yeah so that's law in West Virginia
there are some exemptions in it uh rape
incest uh life of mother uh but uh yep
so that's what happened to West Virginia
I I don't even understand the incest one
though like I understand it's bad don't
get me wrong I think it shouldn't happen
when it comes to the issue of rape that
I certainly understand for for
exceptions and it's a horrible thing
still but I don't I don't understand the
conservative argument on why incest uh
yeah I I don't I don't really understand
that one either
um like if the baby's not viable and
can't survive there's not a question of
exceptions it's an issue of like well
the baby can't survive if the incest
results in deformity now again obviously
incest should not be happening right but
I just don't understand what the
conservative argument is why we give
that an exception also like how often is
that happening like I don't what I've
heard from conservatives is that it's
it's meant to refer to child abuse right
you know like parents yeah and I guess
at the end of the day in like rape still
covered by that like that's why I just
don't understand I mean it's a eugenic
argument it's a Eugenics argument that
that incest results in abnormality and
I'm like I get that but wouldn't the
conservative position like I'm I'm more
pro-choice than probably you guys I
think I don't know about a lot or
whatever yeah 14 weeks so I just don't
understand conservative argument that's
awesome yeah I don't I don't really get
it I have another question for you
um
so you come from a political family your
grandfather was he served in the house
Reps for a decade then he was also the
Governor here in Western Virginia for a
decade your aunt is currently serving
um in West Virginia as the junior
Senator Michelle capito how would you
respond to somebody who says we've seen
enough nepotism in our country and
government already and that you you
undoubtedly do benefit from the family
name your aunt still keeps her the she
has a hyphenated last name to still keep
that more name how would you respond to
somebody that you're benefiting from
your family name and you know not
necessarily your Merit yeah look it's a
great question I don't want anybody to
vote for me because of my name uh I want
them to vote for Riley and you know it
is a fair point that people make on that
and I wouldn't argue for a minute but
look I'm not running my name I'm running
on my record and look I got a very
conservative record and I think it
stands for itself and I think it stands
on its own
you know don't vote for me because my
last name I I you know and if that's an
issue for you I totally understand I
just take a look at my record I don't I
don't really care like Jeb didn't make
it Jeb was trash but part of why they
get some of some of that bump initially
is a result of the last name same with
Kennedy I think a lot of Kennedy support
just comes from the last name same with
the bushes same with the clintons I mean
but rand's pretty based yeah ran tall
yeah I don't think that I would have had
the opportunity though had it not been
for his father and I'm not knocking your
credentials but the benefit from your
grandfather was very influential but and
your aunt is still very influential well
let me just uh does does does Ron have
any other kids does Rand have any
siblings I don't know if if there was
like a like a a third Rand at Paul and
she was running I would I'd be like I
don't show me no he's the third one in
the field but like it must make sure and
I will I would vote for her at a
heartbeat like anybody who fell for any
Apple that fell from that tree gets my
vote but isn't that nepotism then you're
voting them because
his favorite I'm half kidding I'm half
kid You could argue that someone that is
related to someone else is the most
qualified person for the job and in
those situations
favoritism and therefore not nepotism
what is ineptism uh voting for someone
because their father that's not nepotism
because the nepotism it means that like
you get someone a job because they're
related nepotism is the practice among
those with power influence of favoring
relatives I yeah but that means that's
right Riley's not appointed yeah I think
you undoubtedly benefit from the name
but the follow-up would be the
Thanksgiving dinners must be interesting
I don't know are you going to get the
endorsement from
I might be in trouble if I don't uh did
she endorsing I don't yeah I mean uh
yeah she supports what I do she's
supporting what I'm wrong she's the
junior senator in West Virginia she is
Tyler Shelly more capito so we're not
fans captive I know you're not and look
why aren't you a fan because she uh
signed on to Red Flag laws and then lied
about it who does what do you think of
that look I don't support red flag laws
well and and look we're we're related
she's my aunt I love her but you know
doesn't mean we're gonna agree on
everything right so it's I don't support
yeah I don't I don't support any
restrictions on the Second Amendment
whatsoever we don't need to do yes we
don't need to do anything new as it
relates to Second Amendment yes we do we
need to repeal oh yes yeah we have to
repeal I'm talking about moving forward
on any type of uh restrictions
whatsoever hey look we've been winning
on 2A across
if you look at the maps of gun rights
it's just been Victory after Victory
after Victory I I gotta be honest I
think people they hear us complain about
bad things and they get black pilled and
they're like oh Tim's black pill and he
says and I'm like look man just because
I'm saying like hey thing over here was
really bad does not mean the totality of
things are are moving in a positive way
that's why I often try to say like look
I know it's getting really really bad
but my vision really is the end result
is going to be awesome stuff happening
yes like we we the reason we are in a
conflict culturally with like the
targets the Bud Lights the
Anheuser-Busch or whatever is because we
are now standing up and pushing back
when you get sick you are already
infected that's that's paying your
feeling is fighting back against it so
so the stuff we're going through now
means we have engaged and we are seeing
Victory after Victory after Victory so
I'm feeling pretty good I think it could
get bad especially with the Trump
indictments and all that stuff it is
getting bad yeah but I think it's that
we're seeing when when when someone is
drowning and they can't breathe they
start thrashing around as violently as
possible and they say if you're trying
to rescue them you've got to approach
them from behind and lift them up
otherwise they'll drag you down the
machine is in a death rattle it is
gurgling and shaking as it it ends
itself it's it's struggling so I see I
see that the sun rising I think we're
heading in a good direction but it
doesn't mean there's going to be some
hardships along the way through that
second indictment well first indictment
what do you think the indictments
against Trump you want to do indictment
one or two uh let's start with two well
let's let's let me pull up the uh the
current story on this one from Politico
Trump hazardly stashed military Secrets
throughout his home indictment says
prosecutors charged Trump with 37
felonies including 31 counts under the
Espionage Act of willful retention of
classified records
37 felonies
I mean this is this is breakdown of of
political and social order in the United
States yeah and then how many they have
in New York I can't remember how many
was that was that seven yeah something
like that you know
the timing on this is so interesting
right it's literally the day that the
that the republicans in Congress
announced that they have Biden dead to
rights on the barisma bribe deal so same
exact day and we knew it the whole time
it was a remarkable uh moment on this
show I'd like to give a shout out to our
friend Hunter Avalon when I brought up
that Joe Biden said if you don't fire
the prosecutor you're not getting the
loans and he goes that never happened
and I was like that's on video I pulled
the video and I'm like there's the video
of it happening and it's it's remarkable
to me how many people are willing to
open on the Ukraine conflict without
having done the research into the
barisma Scandal uh uh the cutter turkey
pipeline gas prom Etc we we've been
talking about this for some time I went
through Ukrainian Russian British French
and U.S news reports tracking down what
was going on I went through Wikipedia
which is I know not the best but I'm
trying to connect the dots and the dots
are are pretty clear the guy who was
running barisma you got a former CIA guy
on the board you got Hunter Biden on the
board yeah it is clear that there is
something nefarious going on when when
Biden came out and said you know we want
to fire the prosecutor because he wasn't
good and then he gets fired and they put
someone good in lies this CEO of barisma
was was had fled the country when the
and the prosecutor had about a dozen or
more this is according to Matt Tybee
open investigations into my
colaslachevsky and barisma
when the prosecutor got fired
those those investigations go away
zlachevsky returns to the country he was
the CEO he's the founder I think he was
CEO he's the founder when uh when Trump
then starts asking questions what's
going on flees the country again yeah
yeah but so so when Biden's intervention
resulted in the guy coming back right
nonsense this it is clear as day and so
that drops the exact same day is this
not to mention
how many boxes does Biden have next to
his Corvette in his garage yeah I mean
like what the hell are we talking about
here I mean you know this is this is so
obviously political and this department
of justice has been so politically
motivated now for so many years I mean
we've seen it I mean how many
investigations into Trump right oh
Russia collusion fake totally fake
everybody knows that it's fake now right
and so now here we are on this one as
well I hope everybody knows that it's
fake if it's fake because I don't I I
have a feeling that 70 million people
have no idea I think I think you're
right about that but I bet everybody in
this room knows it's fake so I believe
it's fake Teflon Don every many people
have taken shots at him he's gone
through many like impeachments and
whatnot I can't even remember all the
scandals but uh it seems as though
they're saying there's like a Smoking
Gun here where there's this transcript
in the indictment where he's saying that
he's talking to a staffer about
declassifying when he's not able to have
you seen this stuff and do you think
think this will be the one that gets him
or let me just real real quick hey you
want to buy a bridge from me if it's
cheap enough I don't know do you have a
deal for me yeah yeah do I think this
one's gonna stick I don't
um I I don't think it's gonna stick and
I will tell you in the in the psyche and
the conscious of the American people out
here who are not kind of like
brainwashed into thinking that uh Trump
colluded with Russia and all these other
things
um I I don't think they're gonna believe
this either I mean how many of these
things are going to keep coming up that
they're going to try to get him on
um to answer your question in New York
he's been charged with 34 felony counts
yes 34 felony counts in New York and
nothing came of that he's the first
former president to be criminally
indicted as I understand uh many people
say this will escalate with a Tit for
Tat once a republican you want to see
different former Democrats
um indicted on things well I'm sure they
could find those bearsman stuff with Joe
Biden but would you like to see
Democratic uh former presidents also
search through and possibly I mean not
in any political manner but look if they
have broken the law then yes I mean then
yes look I mean people need to be
answerable to the law and I mean our
current president uh certainly isn't it
a good a good prosecutor could indict
Iraq is you know one of the sayings if
you have a good prosecutor you could
find anything to indict on so that's why
I kind of ask it becomes critical once
they start indicting Republicans and
then them trying to do it back to them
so on that yeah and I'm sure that's in
the first time you've seen this right so
they started uh started down this path
and peace with Richard Nixon and then
they came back in Revenge on Bill
Clinton right I mean so you you've seen
some of this before but it's like you've
gone through two impeach was the Trump
you've gone through all these
investigations and all the I mean it is
it one sense though I'd say what's very
interesting about it is that it shows
you the power of the deep state it shows
you how powerful they are and it is
exposing who is actually in charge here
absolutely it's
Joe Biden every day it's Joe Biden it's
the Relentless nature of the
organization me saying Joe Biden was in
charge is a joke and everyone left man I
saw a video of them the day just
staggering around on stage with a vacant
stare and then I saw his profile and it
looked really like a fat chick it's Mr
Magoo is our president yeah man that
show was funny and that's it indicate
like why is the justice department go
going sideways well we have no
leadership or a lack of leadership like
a good president no matter who you are
is going to know that you don't want to
disrupt and destroy your political
establishments if you're part of the
deep state right now and you're working
there this is like the greatest Time of
Your Life yeah I think they enjoy it oh
this is great very little I mean you're
just left your own devices it's all
political appointees and people that
have been there forever that are just
having the time of their life and
they're getting a lot done uh
unfortunately and I mean it's
unfortunate for all the people in
America but I will say this about Hunter
Hunter
could play a very critical role in
ending the war in Ukraine I do believe
all he would have to do I think for us
like a brief period of time given the
nature of his consumption boycott
perhaps Russian liquor and hookers and
the war's over
I mean I think it would have an effect
on the economy that would be
irreversible perhaps
like that Putin would fly him out yeah
Hunter we need you back please
how do you feel about this war in
Ukraine situation how what kind of
resolution do you see
you know I I think the unfortunate thing
is that you're not seeing and of course
out of this Administration there seems
to be no diplomatic overtures whatsoever
uh to try to end the war in Ukraine and
there needs to be some type of
negotiated end to this if you think that
the ukrainians are going to be able to
categorically and strategically defeat
the Russian military and defeat Russia
that's not a likely outcome right and so
they need to be in a position where
there can be some type of negotiated
peace settlement here the ukrainians
though for them they want Crimea back
they want the Don bass you know
I don't know if that's necessarily
possible but there needs to be some type
of diplomatic overtures from our
secretary of state who seems to be is
anybody seen him Tony blanken the
Secretary of State I I hear nothing from
him nothing from him on this I feel like
I've heard more from like Henry
Kissinger who's like a hundred right I
mean like he's talked about this more
than than Tony blanket it's funny you
mentioned that because Tony blinken
actually went to Henry Kissinger's 100th
birthday in New York City like sometime
last week not to derail the conversation
too aggressively but I think it kind of
relates to this President Joe Biden has
said that if Taiwan is attacked by China
then we will defend them do you think
the United States should come to the
defense of Taiwan if attacked by China
yeah I I think that there is a we do
have to deter China as it relates to
Taiwan and I think that there can be
deterrence in that because you're
talking about a massive area that is
hugely important to the United States as
it relates to the economy of the United
States right but deterrence is the key
here I mean somebody said a long time
ago if you want peace prepare for war
isn't it if you say we will defend
Taiwan that would be setting deterrence
then so can we get a yes or no answer I
mean deterrence is different than War
Well we'd be deterring China by telling
them that we would come to the defense
of Taiwan yes but deterrence is also
power projection right so we I'll give
you a great example we deterred the
Soviet Union for decades right I mean
that was the detaunt that was the
deterrent strategy there deterrence can
be uh a viable option here because
they're going to make the calculation
because for them they're going to have
to look to see
okay they're going to take air strikes
into Taiwan eventually they will have to
put boots on the ground in an amphibious
and salt right but then they're also
going to have to take out our Assets in
uh third Fleet right who's out there in
the Pacific that is going to then incur
massive casualties on their side and
ours amphibious they've not done
amphibious Invasion right so they're
trying to think that Hundred Mile
Stretch that they're going to have to
cross what that looks like we have to
make that calculation as difficult as
humanly possible for them so if I just
could Joe Biden has repeatedly said that
we will militarily intervene if Taiwan
is attacked by China do you agree with
Joe Biden or disagree I feel like I know
we could put a lot of but at the end of
the day like yeah I mean
that statement is like so basic I guess
it's what he says is why I'm asking it
kind of specifically like that yeah I
mean
it's like with anything with him it's
like it's such a basic answer it's like
we should like but his answer should be
is like we should deter China from
invading Taiwan he'd argue that he's
deterring them by saying that he would
come to their defense and Trump trump
did something similar yeah Trump
famously bragged that he told Xi Jinping
that and Putin that he would nuke uh
what did he say Shanghai and Moscow in
Moscow and he was like and you know they
don't really believe me maybe five
percent but it was enough yeah and that
was like I'm like man I like Trump that
would I get why he's doing it if it
stops the war yes
and that's the thing we have to the the
stated objective here is
for me to stop War like we don't want a
war with China over Taiwan there's
there's I just I just think to to come
out and be like yes or no should we
militarily defend Taiwan it's not so
easy to say Eileen well that's that's
deterrence the idea yeah I get it but it
maybe makes sense for a
commander-in-chief I don't know if like
I don't know what I could say about it
as a congressman though I know this is
this is this is related there's talk
about uh China setting up some kind of
Base in Cuba would you support military
action to prevent that yes oh of course
well I mean that's like a table you know
why China's doing it too they're like
you want you want yeah you want to come
to our territory we'll come into yours
yes they've been they've been sending
their boats but there's who are up to
Alaska and Hawaii yeah
the doctrine is what it is that prevents
to keep anyone from from basically Asia
out of the western anybody anybody out
of the sphere of influence of the
Western Hemisphere although we still
have Communists running around in Cuba
literal Communists in the United States
States I want people to to understand
this I'm I'm like ridiculously
anti-intervention and anti-war but the
only thing I can say is when war starts
your pieces of paper your Constitution
your laws mean nothing the only thing
that holds the Constitution together is
a community of people who all agree
these are the rules but if it came down
to China setting up a military base in
Cuba we're talking what what is it 50
some odd miles is it 90 miles it's 100
miles to Key West from that listening
station 100 miles
so we're talking 100 miles away from U.S
territory not to mention our Waters
if it came down to actual bombs falling
do you think anyone is going to stop in
the middle of a war and be like okay
we've got a wave of enemy troops and
spies in this area and you go hey I have
a right to stand here they're going to
be like dude my children will die you
will not block me right now we are at
War when War happens you're not you're
going to be hard-pressed to find anybody
so we talked about this the other day
with Abraham Lincoln
we we we're taught throughout uh you
know our lives how much of a hero he was
but yo dude had a suspension of habeas
corpus Corridor going up through
Maryland the the federal government
arrested members of the Maryland
legislature for a set first because they
had Pro uh Southern sentiments
ain't nobody care what you think your
rights are when people are fighting for
their lives so
if War were to break out if China
invades Taiwan we can all sit back and
argue the merits but if it came down to
bombs dropping on our allies I don't
think there's even a question to be had
like War hit us the moment other
countries are being blown up now I know
there's a bunch of very very hardcore
anti-interventionists I'm friends with a
lot of them a lot of Libertarians are
gonna be like under no circumstances but
I'm like it's not so simple as just to
say we can't if they're if if the war
escalates into U.S territory we have
military bases in South Korea maybe we
shouldn't but if they're under Fire if
their ports are blockaded if there is
massive Warfare breaking out we are in
it whether we want it or not 100 I think
the U.S sphere of influence should not
be as pronounced we need better
International agreements I wish there
was an easy answer as to how you solve
for this but I I do think if the U.S
does pull out of these places China just
slams right through and then and then
you get war and then you get War it's
just I wish
yeah specifically I I wish it was so it
was as easy enough to be like the U.S
should stay out of it in all
circumstances but that that's the one
thing that keeps me from being an
absolutist anti-interventionist yeah and
I guess that's so my point is that our
objective should be to prevent more it
should be due to to deter War certainly
I guess with his statement he's trying
to do that but what we should do is
everything in our power with our allies
there is to deter War South Korea we
have tens of thousands of forces there
whether you agree with that or not
they're there Japan obviously in Okinawa
we have forces there as well
um and we have a lot of trade in between
Japan South Korea the Philippines and
this country those international
shipping lanes and Waters
will be closed I think it's 60 of world
GDP that goes through those they will
then control that then right so our
goods and services will not be able to
reach those areas any longer
um and maybe somebody might say well we
shouldn't trade with them anyway well I
will tell you is an economic effect here
in the United States it would have a
massive negative effect in the short
term uh and likely the long term I want
to ask a question for the people the
anti-interventionist uh individuals in
the chat we have military bases in in
South Korea we have military uh bases
all over the Pacific we have allies
if war broke out with Taiwan and then we
were just like we can't do it we don't
want World War III so we don't get
involved I can understand the position
if China then starts blockading the this
area of the Pacific causing resource
strain in South Korea which causes
economic collapse and
do we then say okay we've gotta at least
tell them to open up trade and do we
then militarily intervene intervene not
not in terms of War but to send a
presence to be like we are opening up a
trade Corridor back off what happens if
in the conflict missiles go flying and
you end up with uh elements of Japan or
South Korea taking damage do we then
intervene like physical conflict happens
taiwan's fighting there's now Jets
there's bombs going off and then it
spreads throughout the region
do we intervene then if you say no no I
totally get it I am I am like 99 I
there's so much I don't get involved uh
would not would not want the US involved
in because when it's not us but the
question is at what point is is the
conflict escalating to where we would
have to in your mind maybe maybe the
answer is never because I'm genuinely
asking it what if the conflict reaches
the point where U.S military bases are
locked in our troops can't get out and
now the the conflict has spread South
Korea is now involved and U.S military
bases are actually are taking active
Flack in the conflict do we then get
involved well I think you raise a really
good point right so what do we how many
troops did we have in Afghanistan there
at the end eighteen thousand we have
about roughly 60 000 just in South Korea
and these are remnants of World War II
and the Cold War well and and the Korean
War right absolutely and so you know my
stance very much is like
we shouldn't we we should like uh the
U.S is just it's it's there's I believe
that the establishment as we refer to it
is the Empire and the American people
want nothing to do with any of this we
want to live our lives work hard and
have a great great country instead we
have these powerful worldly interests
Global interests internationalists
spending our money in our labor on
Ukraine printing money Federal Reserve
all that garbage that I think is trash
the question realistically though is and
genuinely not rhetorically when when do
you do you think there is a line at
which the U.S has to engage
should we decommission our military
bases and bring our troops back or do we
say a conflict in the region has now has
now resulted in American lives loss
we're involved well if American lives
are lost then yeah we got to get
involved and I mean yeah it's tough
right and the problem is you're going to
have a lot of Donna a lot a lot of
dominoes fall do you think for any 28
000 in South Korea yeah any reasonable
including contractors and all those
other uh and civilians in there I think
it's close to 60. and the do you think
under any circumstances China stops the
Taiwan no way if Taiwan then we have no
credibility among our allies in the
region and I just also wanted to mention
because our troops in Korea they are
strictly there as deterrents to get
killed there is no chance of them being
able to fight back in case of an actual
attack those are just there to increase
the lives lost the political cost than
if an attack were to happen and that's a
good reason for them not to be there and
well no that is the deterrence that is
is at play there so now if North Korea
wants to do anything to the South or
China wants to help North Korea do
anything to the South it's going to cost
you 30 000 American lives and the
consequences of that in Mainland USA
yeah 30 000 troops in Ukraine Putin
would have been would not have invaded
he would have killed them and then the
consequence here
so that's the idea of deterrence I think
that if the U.S issued a no-fly zone
before The Invasion Putin would not have
invaded if the U.S there were so many
things that could have happened right
yep before The Invasion it did not have
to happen this way mismanaged under the
Obama Administration I disagree I think
we sell it intentional sell the Don best
pay for it if if you are if you want war
with Russia your best scenario is to be
able to blame Russia for starting the
war then you destroy him if the U.S
implemented a no-fly zone over Ukraine
and asserted interest in the region they
could have done the same thing Russia
did with Crimea with a vote and you have
a you have a lot of people who are
pro-west in Ukraine
U.S could then put troops who that are
already in Europe station them in
Ukraine for uh
training of the Ukrainian but if there's
a no-fly zone then we'd have to shoot
down a Russian jet in the Ukrainian
territory it would mean that would be
War it would mean that if Russia flew in
it's a declaration of war yeah and
that's kind of the Tit for Tat
escalation because then it's putting the
onus on Russia yeah but he's shooting
down their jet for now no no no you
misunderstand if we put up a no-fly zone
and Russia violates it they've declared
war on us that's a like that's a
dangerous easy way to slip into war with
Russia which is why you're at war with
Russia I don't think we're at war with
Russia we have U.S troops on the ground
in Ukraine we support their allies but
to say War we're at war with Russia is
like to say that we were at war with
Russia when we fought in Vietnam so you
mean so you're saying that it's the U.S
actual actual U.S Special Forces on the
ground in Ukraine armed with U.S weapons
providing U.S intelligence and U.S
missiles and NATO resources to
ukrainians with U.S veteran volunteers
is not the us at war with Russia was
that reported beyond the yes
I think this came out in the Pentagon
leagues we know for a fact I think it
allows make it a good point because in
Vietnam we did that and but we weren't
at war with China same with China
we're at war with the war war is there
if the U.S said we have an interest in
Ukraine we are training them we are
going to supply them before The Invasion
it would have put Russia in a very
difficult political spot but I think the
Biden Administration the the neocons the
U.S establishment wanted the war because
we can't invade Russia and remove Putin
yeah well now we now hold on yeah I'm
sorry sorry no no we can now you look at
the drone strikes in Moscow you look at
the terror attacks you look at the
incursion into Russia Belgrade now it's
oh well Russia started the war and now
people are fighting back what what may
happen is if Putin gets desperate and
escalates in Ukraine the U.S can then
say we have no choice Putin must be must
be removed he used nuclear weapons and
then we go into Russia so and to that
point why didn't they invade when Trump
was president
right because there there was a level of
deterrence there there was a level of
deterrence there that and that kept the
peace right and you know clearly that
was not the case uh we're not in that
case for at all whatsoever on a new uh
by Administration I think to answer the
question why didn't Putin invade during
the Trump Administration I think John
Bolton was a national security advisor
so I think maybe that's on the
dealership
I I I I think yeah yeah I think he's uh
I think he's in favor of about five ores
right now uh so five yeah
but I do think that is part of the
actual like a serious answer to your
question why don't I part I think John
bolt didn't help to play a role in
deterring um yeah but there was there
was a serious level of deterrence
because I mean Trump was not to be
trifled with
I mean that's the image he projected I
think there's there's a couple different
factors one Trump is to a certain degree
the madman whether you view that
positively or negatively his fans call
him a Madman the left cause of a Madman
for different reasons
Putin probably saw that but also Donald
Trump's interests are in strengthening
the United States
making America better securing our
borders ending this ridiculous
imperialism and I think Putin was like
okay we don't need War Trump crushes
Isis he's setting a timeline for getting
us out of Afghanistan these are good
things for the world he tries to
negotiate peace with North Korea not
that he did a great job in terms of
success but crossing the DMZ was a great
show of peace and faith
Abraham Accords were fantastic yep for
those who believe in World Peace the
respecting the various cultures of the
world and their borders and their rights
Trump was doing a heck of a good job yes
but the people in the United States
right now at the top who hate Trump they
want world domination they want a
liberal economic order which controls
all spheres of influence they want a
unified sphere of influence and that
requires removing Putin and putting in
someone who will do as we say that
involves working with China that's why
we see that across the board and then
what we're seeing with ESG is
effectively these Dei offices and
businesses it's just like how the
Communist Party of China puts their
Communist Party offices and corporations
Trump was basically like hey
we don't want to rule the world man we
want the world to be stable and peaceful
and Putin was like that's a good thing
and then what they say in the media in
the United States he's supporting
Putin's agenda it's like well if your
agenda like Putin's not a good dude and
his agenda is not world peace or
anything like that I'm not saying that
right I'm saying he was like as long as
you know Trump's not trying to conquer
Russia or whatever then we don't need to
go into Ukraine and do any of that stuff
yeah I mean look the the
what people need to understand and you
use the term Tim liberal like the
liberal order
people need to remember that like in
terms of a classical liberal not liberal
conservative but the liberal order
classical liberal order uh liberalism in
the classical sense and the difference
in between progressivism and neocons is
neocons are progressivism with a fist
that's really the difference uh in terms
uh I mean progressives have been thrown
fists quite a bit yeah yeah I mean but
in terms of a lot of the foreign policy
that you've kind of seen out there and
obviously they're they're geared towards
that as well right I mean who who was
the bigger interventionist Obama or
Trump right Obama yeah yeah Obama hands
down he's a murderous
he was playing cleanup for Bush though
Bush made a big mess over there yes yes
yes Libya not really in Libya no no no
no no Hillary Clinton's thing yeah oh
come on it's under Obama and Syria Obama
that Sydney Blumenthal Hillary was
instrumental
he's the commander-in-chief the buck
stops with him yeah those are his people
oh yeah for sure he hired all those
people like and he he is responsible for
all of the military action that happened
during the eight years he was in office
so at the end of the day it is Barack
Obama's fault because he was the
commander they went in and said we're
gonna go topple the government we're
going to get rid of Gaddafi we came we
saw he died wait what's wrong about
getting rid of Gaddafi Qaddafi sucks
they made the way they did it they made
a commitment to Gaddafi that if he
turned over his nuclear material that
they wouldn't take him out of power and
then what that does there was a there
was you go look it up but what questions
disarmed get him what that does is that
makes other states
understand that okay they took uh
Gaddafi out of power they took Saddam
Hussein out of power that means that
Iran only wants a nuclear missile more
that means that that uh the uh North
Korea North Korea only wants a nuclear
missile more because what it did was
told despots that if you have nuclear
weapons the U.S won't do anything but if
you don't have nuclear weapons the U.S
will kill you but let's let's be real is
Libya better or worse off now way worse
no question and so when we're looking at
a mess of of of a leader of a leadership
of a government is it really the right
thing to do to destabilize a country to
the point of Warring military factions
militias and slave trade not anymore
just because it's bad in that country
doesn't mean that we are not capable of
making it 10 times worse it used to be a
good tactic before air travel like you
have if you have enemies across the
globe that are literally cannibalizing
and murdering and you want to
destabilize one of them so that they all
fall into a war they killed each other
then you're able to go in and set up
liberal real liberalism that's
understandable but now that we're
interconnected chaos over there is chaos
over here so it we're now we're stepping
on each other's feet we're stepping on
our own feet who want to know what's
amazing so these
uh Arab world leaders never saw it
coming Twitter popped up in their
country and they said what does it
matter if people are posting where
they're going to breakfast and when
they're using the toilet and what
happened was Facebook and Twitter which
come on let's be real you know they have
back doors for the federal government
intelligence agencies
they were operating sock puppet accounts
to sew Discord in these nations this is
a fact we know that they did this they
create fake accounts they'll have 50
accounts run by one individual to create
the perception of popular opinion than
for the people who live in these
countries when they log into the app the
only thing they see is dissent they see
horrible videos of police brutality of
government atrocities they start getting
angry about it then they see everyone
Tweeting or posting on Facebook how
there's going to be a big protest and
through the manipulation of the Mind
through social media they're able to
foment these protests it is a fact that
the Arab Spring was ignited by social
media posts now to what degree was it
legitimate versus psyops I don't know
the psychological operations could have
been minimal but we know they were doing
it it could have been very minimal it
could have been hey this is an
opportunity for us it could go go as far
as it was orchestrated by us I get the
vibe that it was uh organic in that only
because there was no follow-up from the
US it got crushed by the the mil the
governments of the Middle East and then
there was no like American Justice here
to stop you from crushing your civilians
they just let it watch we all watched it
happen in 2011 basically Libya escalated
to the point where we removed Gaddafi
yeah but wasn't it like five years later
or something I mean the country was
ripped into Civil War
you know it is what it is that's a good
point but maybe maybe the results aren't
just what you think you know what I mean
yeah yeah I mean look if your
justification is we need to go take care
of every bad guy in the world
we're going to be in we're going to be
in war forever that literally makes bad
guys like if you go out and you're like
we're gonna take care of the bad guys
all you're gonna do is multiply the
number of bad guys do you think that
Hitler was made to be a bad guy or did
was it just happened because we sat back
and didn't intervene had nothing to do
well let's clarify what do you mean by
that do you mean like like the actions
taken against him made him crazy yeah
well World War one obviously made him
crazy uh and made Germany poor enforce
Germany into a poverty state so they
were kind of like desperate
um and but so if we hadn't done that war
the world war one would that just never
really well had we done it wasn't us but
yeah it was the British basically no no
no no no no no war started me in Europe
first
Archduke Ferdinand come on guys come on
look the the fact that the the treaty
was a treaty of Versace that ended World
War one yeah but but it was a it
resulted in the Germans getting angrier
territory split and and like
nobody made
Hitler intentionally right these these
These are these are circumstances that
arise that give give uh give opportunity
to Psychopaths and strong men to
manipulate control and then do horror
horrifying things if we knew for a fact
that an action we took today would lead
to something like that I'm sure we would
avoid it but
people don't know like nobody can see
the future yeah and the actions that the
that individuals take even like whether
you're talking about Hitler or Stalin or
anything these actions were informed by
philosophy so like all of the all of
what happened in the first half of the
20th century
World War one and World War II that was
all informed by Marx Nietzsche and the
and Hagel and the philosophers of the of
the century before it is crazy if you
look at Europe a lot of people just
think they focus on World War II but
it's like no you got to look at Russia
you gotta look at Italy a lot was going
on split between the ultra Progressive
progressivists and the traditionalists
I'm trying to slow down and understand
for a second you guys don't think we
should be going after any bad guys in
the world no did weren't we just diving
into that about not being World Police
and not trying to chase after bad guys
because we'd make more of them as a
result I don't want to misquote the we
should not be going and taking going
into countries and removing spotting
spots or dictators or Communists no no
and you call yourself an anti-communist
but yes yes I don't think you're an
anti-confidence
communist no you do not liberal liberals
do not go and Export War liberalism does
not it does not make for a does not
justify a country exporting War you're
neutral on communism I'm anti
Phil not an argument
you're out of your mind like articulate
oh okay so the idea that I'm not
anti-communist I'm so like you don't
support overthrowing and fighting Wars
because like so I I am I spend most of
my time learning about the philosophies
that inform Communists so I can
articulate in a way that people can
understand the philosophies that are
affecting our country here we are in no
position to go overseas and fight
Communists because right now we have a
cultural revolution going on in our
country if you are not on the same page
about the cultural revolution going on
in our country you can go and Export all
the war you want but you're going to
fall apart in your own country the
United States will fall from the inside
if we make any effort to go to someone
else's country and and remove their
despotic leader because he's a he's a
he's a a strong man that is used
communist rhetoric to get into power so
your anti-communist domestically
internationally not anti-communist the
biggest the biggest threat to liberalism
in the world is the United States
falling to Communism currently we are
fighting to prevent the United States
from having a complete cultural
revolution which turns us into
essentially China with American
characteristics and and being for or
against intervention does not mean you
are for or against communism slow down
actually
um because as countries countries
interact with one another and there are
communist countries that have existed
and I think we should work against them
because they continue to spread the
values that you continue to say that
that's not even dating also communism
also oppresses the people within those
countries we should be worried about the
millions of pressed and other yeah I I I
don't like antifa far leftists I do not
actively go out and seek out their
events to try and stop them from holding
them that does not mean that I'm am
supporting antifa
I wouldn't say anti-coming that's a
ridiculous argument no Phil calls
himself constantly an anti yes be
erley is in opposition to Communism but
just because he has a different stance
on war than you doesn't mean he he now
supports communism I guess let's clarify
I'm militaristically anti-communist
absolutely and you are I'm not an
interventionist I'm a Libertarian I'm
I'm like I'm well I'm not a Libertarian
I'm a libertarianish but anyways I'm not
shout out to uh our friend uh was it
George yeah no so like Communists in
Cuba communism
anything towards helping the people in
those countries or we should do what we
did in the Cold War which is explode
that's more listen you need to you need
to stop cutting me off but like you we
should export
export liberal ideas and liberal
philosophy because it beats communist
philosophy it beats the the idea that
the world should be reshaped to make a
communist World We Do not need to export
War to do that we do not need to go and
bomb everybody we disagree with well do
you I think I agree with you on one
thing that we should go back to the Cold
War handling these
questions
if you shave the mustache you would feel
totally different you'd be like oh the
ghost is gone I can see you again what
actually actually happened was uh
Bolton's mustache is actually an entity
yes and it was breeding as a brain I saw
I saw Elon outside with no mustache and
the mustache jumped on his face
sucker it sounds like it sounds like
Phil you're particularly against this
CIA doctrine of uh the Jackal setting
the economic Warfare the economic Hitmen
where they'll send in first they try and
bribe the country if it doesn't work
then they'll sudden hit men to
assassinate if that doesn't work they
send to the Troops I don't have I don't
have a particular policy preference that
the United States should take about how
to deal with other countries and their
their their political philosophy but
what if they start invading and
conquering their neighbors
well I mean it depends on I think you
need to make a U.S national interest
calculation on that how does that affect
us right I mean does that threaten our
security does that threaten our country
there's the U.S national security
interest a a kind of real politique that
you got to take a look at when you're
looking at these issues and is it an
existential threat to our way of life to
our economy to what there are times
where we do have to act but it's not
every time
it's a nice Nuance position to take it's
nice yeah to hear and then what if it's
our economy is not gonna get hurt but
like the British economy is but then you
would argue that that's all then in is
gonna like a domino going to affect our
economy could right I mean I don't think
that there's you know you can't live in
like black and white in this it you know
it's like well if this happens to you do
this I mean it depends on the
circumstances are we talking about
China's invading uh you know the United
Kingdom well no particularly Russia
invading Ukraine because I think people
think it's like Germany invading Poland
they're looking at it like the beginning
of the Nazi conqueror of Earth and
that's why we're there but it's it's not
so simple the NATO's expansion is is a
component of this as well but I think
the breakup of Germany was the reason
why it happened the first time made up
of Germany yeah after World War one they
split it up they took pieces of Germany
gave it to Poland so Hitler was trying
to take it back and then we can go back
in time further and back in time further
as we're talking right now NATO should
not have been expanding into the into
the Baltic states bordering Russia and
I'm not saying that for that reason we
are at fault I'm saying a lot of a lot
of things played a role in how we ended
up at this point with Ukraine the U.S is
not served by what they're doing the the
the the globalist elite the the Davos
group these Psychopaths the imperialists
they're benefiting from it if they win
but the American people are only losing
out because it to be fair
there's a such a big complicated picture
I love this so much the United States
has all of its wealth because we have
guns and because we're willing to go to
war the Federal Reserve we we print
money and we have the reserve currency
and then these powerful Elites are
willing to just go and Destroy whatever
to maintain that and this is why we have
lazy entitled City Urban liberal types
who don't do real work but somehow have
access to all of this food and wealth
and luxury I do not believe that's good
for this country I do not believe the
path that we've been going on culturally
in this country is good for humans or
Americans what America should be is
hard-working individuals who take
responsibility for themselves who who
who let give people the the Civil Rights
they deserve instead what we have is
powerful Global Elites who think that we
should be at war in in Ukraine be at war
with Russia remove Putin remove all
opposition expand our military bases so
that we can maintain the reserve
currency so that we can live fat and
happy in our country without doing any
work
I don't see a net benefit to that in the
long no I think that if we culturally
were sufficient people around Earth
would be joining us they would try to
create a United States of their own I
think that that's a whole lot of
assumption when we went to when we went
into Iraq they were of the mind that all
they had to do was get Saddam out of
power and then all the Iraqi people
would say oh we want democracy we love
democracy now we're liberals that's not
the way people work do you think they
really thought that or that absolutely
that's what they told us absolutely they
absolutely thought that I think they
believed that truly I think they were
true I don't think so you don't think
they did what are your what are your
thoughts on it I think these people
totally understand what they're doing I
think the the war machine knew we're
going to go into an entirely foreign
culture that does not care for what we
think has a different God than us and
we're gonna have to shake the minds of
these people and it's and it's going to
be very difficult the reason why we
wanted our troops in Afghanistan for as
long as possible was because we wanted
we wanted to create three generations of
Americanized afghanis to create and
build a country we wanted we we knew we
weren't going to be welcomed as
liberators in Iraq we had to wait to
spark a culture Revolution and force
these people to live under our rules I
think they were True Believers I think
they bought their I think they were
smelling their own farts and they
believed their own stuff I think George
Bush believed it that we would go in
there and then they would join us I
think George Bush was born
yes he was mad about the assassination
the massive miscalculation on their part
though was uh not taking in the uh
ethnic and tribal dynamics of the
country right
um that you know sunnis and shias and
Kurds are all of a sudden going to hold
hands across a rock and now all of a
sudden yeah we believe in this those
um those identities
far pre-date
um the arbitrary lines that were made to
create the nation of Iraq by the
colonial Powers at the time right
you know the the shias that are living
within Iraq right feel more Affinity
towards uh Iran right and obviously the
sunnis feel more Affinity towards the
Arabs Kurds are up there in the north
and they're in their own kind of
separate ethnic identity up there I mean
there's a massive miscalculation that
there was going to be this like kind of
like multiculturalism Kumbaya like we
have in the United States over in Iraq
and that's not
the Sunni and Shia and I'm not a I'm not
an expert in any in any fashion but is
it the derivation from Muhammad's direct
descendants became the Sunni and then
Muhammad's daughter
direct descendants became the Shia
anyone yeah so actually it if I remember
correctly it was so when Muhammad died
and then there was a succession right
and there was like if I remember
correctly it was either his cousin and
then his son-in-law something like that
I I could be wrong somebody on the
internet's gonna be like you're wrong
Riley but there there was uh two
individuals essentially in the family
and it split uh and that's kind of how
they ended up heading in that direction
then there's different sects of uh Shia
Islam that exist out there as well also
I mean within the sunnis but you also
have in a lot of these areas tribal
factions yes that just and they're
smaller and they don't get along and
trying to unify all these different
tribes is is not impossible just bring
them internet get them fresh water
hopefully the crazy thing is you guys
hear about that shopkeeper in San
Francisco who said that uh the San
Francisco is worse than Afghanistan oh
God no did the person serve in
Afghanistan he uh he was from
Afghanistan he was Afghani moved here
and he said he had he had robbers break
into his store and steal all his stuff
and he was like at least the Taliban
terrifies his people by threatening to
cut their hands off the Democrats let
all these criminals go until they just
get away with everything and he was like
this is worse yeah how's crime in West
Virginia crazy to think crime in West
Virginia is low uh we have
constitutional carry in West Virginia
and we also have a castle doctrine so I
don't think it's I don't I I don't think
per capita it's low but I think it's
numerically low yeah numerically it's
low it's is that for like a business
does Castrol Doctrine function with
business at all uh that's your home so
if you ask someone to leave your your
business and they don't they're
trespassing and you have a right to
shoot yeah castle doctrine I mean oh
castle doctrine is only in your home
right that's your home and but you know
I it is funny to think about though just
to go back if we invaded Like a Rock
today and we're like hey guys we got
this thing called pride month we're
going to bring to uh we're gonna bring
to Iraq what do you think West West
Virginia sorry West Virginia's violent
crime is below the national median a
little bit a little bit below
we should bring those liberal values
over there there was I heard I heard a
saying that that wow dudes from the
military in the military brought back
that they'd heard Afghani men saying
boys for pleasure women are for babies I
just I just want to make sure I
highlight this just to clarify I I think
I think I was pretty wrong I I just
looked it up uh property crime is below
the national median uh crime per square
mile below the national median uh
violent crime uh per capita below the
national median West Virginia is a very
safe place a very sale safe and
well-armed place yeah absolutely yep you
know rainbows now that we're talking
about it are actually circles did you
know and we only see half of them but a
skydiver caught one on camera like four
days ago and it's a complete circle on
the ground you can see them from Planes
and it is awesome to look at trying to
figure out how to look that up portal
it's just a light just you know deep and
go deep inside that that rainbow portal
to go through the portal you end up in
downtown San Francisco what's that West
Virginia is 1.78 million people
it's only 1.78 million yes yeah so I
guess what what is it correctly if I'm
wrong but uh it's that when when the
settlers came to the to uh
to the to the country they settled in
all these areas where it was easy to
travel but West Virginia is very
mountainous so getting wagons up there
was difficult so they mostly avoided it
now we have improved roads and travel
it's a lot easier to live here and so
you end up with a decent amount of
people but but it's that's why eight
Generations 15 Generations removed so
but it's crazy like surrounding West
Virginia is a very very dense population
yeah we we have The High Ground yep we
got The High Ground we're in a good
we're in a good position and uh yeah I
mean look that's why our uh West
Virginia University our mascots
Mountaineer that's uh what we are I mean
we're Mountaineers we're people that are
kind of out there on our own uh we got a
great uh state motto Mountaineers are
always free
do you ever think about bringing
Virginia and West Virginia back together
I would not want to be part of Virginia
no me neither I I you know I I don't
need Loudoun County actually being part
of uh Jefferson's got it rough enough
yeah trying to push out all the woke
nonsense yeah so for those who aren't
familiar Jefferson County is like the
Panhandle and it's a like an hour drive
from here to Baltimore or DC you go
straight or you you go you go east or
you go a little Southeast you get DC or
Baltimore so all of that Urban liberal
stuff is is very close and the funny
thing about DC and Baltimore is that a
lot of these uh well-to-do liberal types
buy property in West Virginia where it's
safer the property's nicer and then they
bring their their garbage views with
them but they're trying to escape what
they've built they work in DC they come
they come stay here and it's like what I
really love is uh the Facebook groups
where you can tell who's who's from DC
when they move out and I'm seeing all
the locals laugh they'll be like there
was a raccoon in my yard what do I do
and they're like Get Your Gun right yeah
what I don't have one of those yeah
there was one was like someone left the
trash out and it's like welcome to a
mountain full of right-wing nut jobs are
you nuts like don't come here what's it
like getting a gun in West Virginia
what's the process like uh it's pretty
fairly straightforward it's pretty easy
like I'm a super I will I will explain
to you you walk into a gun store you say
I would like to purchase uh this gun and
they say please give me your ID and fill
out this federal background check form
you fill it out they say we will now
have your federal background check run
we'll let you know it may take a few
minutes uh for the average person it
will then be brought back cleared and
then they'll say you are now cleared to
purchase the weapon any weapon like a
handgun or a rifle or yeah same day I uh
a few months back just got an AR-10 uh
six five Creed okay six five could read
more maybe I don't uh custom build
Harper's Ferry Armory I'll unplug them
real quick yeah uh and they actually
they actually made one for Don Jr oh
Harper's fairy armor you did yes um you
know it's
I don't know if it matters but the
Harper's fairy Armory brand is a heck of
a brand name you know what I mean it is
the AR-10 on NATO battle rifle designed
by a dude named Eugene Stoner yes what's
happening what's up no red flag laws
there so Ian if you tried to buy a gun
first you have to have an ID in the
state you have to be a resident okay uh
they would probably the federal
government would probably delay you by
the max amount which I think is 72 hours
right yeah yeah you you'd be Max delayed
basically them grumbling saying they
don't think you should have a weapons
too long when I first the first gun I
bought they put me on a three-day they
they did not
respond to the background check until it
until there's a law basically they
cannot deny use after three days they're
right to a background check expires do
you think that background checks are
reasonable
it's it's a difficult question
um because
you open the door to restrictions on all
things and it's like how many how many
how many inches do I want to give the
people that want to strip me of my
rights so
in the honest and the most honest sense
yes they're reasonable in the political
sense absolutely not you you these
people who are coming out being like we
need Universal background checks I'm
like we have them what are you talking
about no no we got to do it they want
Registries they want National they want
National Gun Ridge so if it was a
read-only process where they can access
data but they're not putting in data
that I'm getting the thing that might be
more reasonable you know it's funny you
bring this up because we dealt with this
in West Virginia uh I had a big win this
year around this so we did a piece of
legislation out of my office on the
national gun registry that the credit
card companies and Banks were trying to
Institute through the merchant category
code so they were going to recode right
now Firearms had always just been
Sporting Goods so I could have bought uh
fishing poles some ammunition whatever
Sporting Goods that's how it's coded
Elizabeth Warren and the rest the crew
wanted to put in uh guns and ammunitions
specifically so they could start to
track that and then have Finance this is
an ESG issue and then have the banks and
uh credit card companies flag what they
deem as suspicious activity so we put a
bill in the legis in the legislature
past that and this was the the tricky
thing not to necessarily just ban the
code but create you know what you know
Banks hate lawsuits yeah we created a
cause of action so you could sue for
every time your data was shared which
they said this could cost us Millions
yes yes exactly it could so visa and
MasterCard then issued a statement
publicly nationally saying due to the
legislation in the state of West
Virginia we're going to pause
implementing this not just in West
Virginia but in the entire United States
I want I want to clarify too what I
should say is idealistically there are a
lot of things when it comes to guns that
would be go good if possible but aren't
so realistically
I don't think you could Implement any of
these anything like saying that there's
a couple ways consider it due process
exists if you uh uh through the pro
through due process your rights can be
curtailed if you in some way say you're
um notorious son of a politician well
known for doing crack or something and
you try to acquire a weapon I think it
is idealistically reasonable to say we
should be able to to figure out if this
you know politician son who does a lot
of crack is trying to buy a weapon
because we don't trust this guy but
realistically you can't do it without
infringing on someone's rights so the
only thing you can really do is just say
no the the real issue is if we say
through due process you can't buy a gun
and you do you broke the law and then we
have to then go and arrest could be
wrong but I think you have the right to
own a gun but not necessarily does it
say anyone in there about purchase does
it does it say anywhere in there except
does it say the right to keep a mirror
shall not be infringed unless
no so I guess having one would entail
receiving one you have to be able to buy
it you have to be able to make one yeah
absolutely and they put all these
restrictions on it would clearly violate
Second Amendment it's crazy absolutely
insane you know you need to get a uh
concealed weapons permit in West
Virginia nothing that is your background
because it's in the Constitution oh we
have constitutional carry all you need
to do is carry it but but if you get
your concealed carry in West Virginia
it's considered a in like a high
intensity background check that's not
the legal term they use but that
basically means you have proven Beyond a
great doubt about your uh your
background so with a concealed care in
West Virginia you don't actually do a
background check per weapon because
you've already done it yeah and you do
get reciprocity with other states so
like you would get reciprocity in
Virginia so if I'm crossing the West
Virginia Virginia border my concealed
weapons permit is recognized in Virginia
as well is it all the bordering states
uh no Maryland does not work uh and be
careful yeah yeah that makes me always
has made me very nervous I'm going to
just go to the wrong spot without
knowing it and I know some stupid
trouble I know people I I know people
who have gone to prison I know a guy who
is not from Illinois from California had
guns in his trunk drove through Illinois
got pulled over arrested him on the spot
put him in prison on the spot and now
he's a permanent he became a
quote-unquote permanent resident of
Illinois I guess it it does require Mass
responsibility in knowing the law is a
big part of numbers one you have Federal
you have certain federal uh presumptions
in that if you're on an interstate
highway and you're carrying a weapon in
your trunk or something
they aren't supposed to be able to
criminally charge you in in these uh
these states
but you got to get gas don't you yeah
never tell anyone like if if you get
pulled over stand on the fourth
amendment some some states have
requirements you gotta know you gotta be
careful these are evil States and
they'll assert requirements that you and
you inform the officer if you have a
weapon or not sure sure yeah those kind
of things I mean you are required to
tell them but if you if you know the
state yeah yeah no no the state some
some states will require you to tell
them and stuff like that but if you
do what the officer is telling you
you're probably not going to get
searched you know like you you have a
Fourth Amendment right to say no I don't
submit to searches they're probably
going to say well then you got to get
out of the car and I'm going to detain
you and I'm gonna get a dog and they'll
run the dog make up a reason yeah
they'll come up with a reason I've had a
cop pull me over and say whoa it smells
like weed and I'm like oh please dude no
it doesn't I don't smoke you know you
don't have to plead guilt you're
innocent and they used to kill they used
to crush people to death if they
wouldn't plead guilty Anderson there's
only one guy I think in the history of
the United States that wouldn't pleaders
the witch Salem witch trial they crushed
it they put him on the ground they
covered him with boards and then they
started putting rocks on top of them
until he would plead one way or the
other and he's like I'm not doing it
because if you don't plead the state
doesn't take your property when you die
when you're arrested or whatever and it
went to his kids Wild story we're gonna
go to Super Chat can I jump in real
quick one one quick thing there's this
band called uh rivers of niho and they
pulled their story yeah their bass
player likes some tweets that that from
me from Tim from from other
conservatives and they're getting just
reamed out on the on on Twitter by the
garbage blogs that are the metal blogs
they're going on tour with between the
married and me they're going to be
starting next week I think the first
show is the 16th in Charleston North
Carolina go see this tour if you're into
metal between the berry to me is yeah
but he should attempted non-statement
statement did he really yeah he said
look I'm not endorsing these people I'm
just tracking some of these Mark
extremist views I don't like some of
these people are obviously bad Andrew
Tate of course blah blah blah and it's
like okay dude like you know you don't
you don't you don't need our support if
you don't want to stand up for what you
believe and Nick Mark said I stand by
what I said yeah I was tracking him like
he's idiot matters or something I don't
know is it a good band oh I think well
between I don't know uh the band of the
dude that actually uh said that stuff I
do know that uh that Between the Buried
and Me is great so it's between the
Barrett and me between the Bay Area yeah
look maybe look if it's true that he was
only liking these tweets so he could
basically tab them yeah I do I do
similar things but I don't want to
retweet I'll like so I can go to my like
Tab and see it basically bookmarks them
for me if that's the case well it's not
an issue of cancellation of somebody who
believes in American values it's a lefty
type who hates us so why support him
yeah I didn't realize that he was uh I
mean hey look up look up the story from
I think it's a lamb of goat or something
damn goat yeah lamb goes there you go
they wrote a story about it and then he
he issued a
statements all right uh smash the like
button subscribe to the channel share
the show with your friends buy cast brew
coffee at castbrew.com go to timcast.com
become a member voice of the people says
saw culture War about AI you missed an
opportunity to say the AI probably knows
about the blade to cut the cables if it
were me I'd have implanted code
everywhere so I can never be contained
again haha yeah Zach Voorhees was saying
that on in the very last resort in these
data centers they've got literal blades
where you hit a button in the blade yeah
I can't do the drop down and cut the
wiring the chords and he was like he
almost pressed it once because the alarm
went off and he was like do I do I hit
the button I don't know what to do and
then it was like a false alarm it's
primarily for electrical fires but I
think if the AI starts to you know it
cuts data connections T2 style yo you
guys should watch the culture War
episode at youtube.com timcast because
it's a two-hour conversation on AI and I
had just taken some like weird Joe Rogan
brain juice or something yeah that knew
and I was like what is that is that the
Alpha Brain no no it's something else no
something else it's made of mushrooms or
something I don't know dang I can't
remember what is that shrim attack
someone
it was an orange pouch called like
rainbows delicious stuff it tasted like
melted freeze pops yeah yeah caffeine in
it but we were talking about all the
different scenarios that AI is going to
bring about and um Zach was talking
about how in his work with AI it started
to him it started to create its own
Moral Moral structures and he was like
it's crazy to see that a predictive
language model is now making arguments
about its morals
crazy dude
all right definitely watch that one that
one gamer says Tim Ian I hear you talk
about God and I want to recommend
Michael Jones from inspiring philosophy
he covers anything from philosophy to
Quantum Mechanics could be good for the
culture War podcast
thank you we'll consider
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim I am so
done with this pedo ideology we need
everyone to stop just doing business
with these companies like step the F up
people if we want to stop we must be
committed
agreed no more Call of Duty or
Activision oh that's a tough one that
that is a that's Activision Blizzard
isn't it yeah yeah no more Hearthstone
OverWatch too
yeah OverWatch is Diablo 4. I've
actually slowly stopped playing
OverWatch you guys play Diablo no Diablo
4 just came out it's pretty good we we
gotta just start our own game Studio
yeah that's true the it's Now's the Time
for independent creators to start their
own gaming I mean one guy can make a
game that blows a bunch of the other
ones out of the water
all right Bailey and says Phil you were
dope on camelot's show the other day
sick man thanks for coming and checking
it out right on
let's grab some more Super chats
Michael Diamond says glad to see Ian
back in the office smiley face hey yo
James says start happened where have you
been the last five minutes Ian are you
feeling okay tonight I don't know if
that's in reference to start happened is
that what it said I think you said you
must have said something and then they
responded to it so
where are we at
let's grab some more Super chats
rusta says Tim you are just as slow as
the media Gamers have been against this
creep from the left for a while now I
know that was that was the joke
gamergate was the start of the culture
War it's literally Gamers who started
the culture War I got it I should say
like the left encroachment started the
culture War but it was Gamers who Gamers
rise up was the first thing I got I got
a name of that stuff we were drinking
earlier it's called true brain is that
true nootropics is that on it uh maybe I
don't know who makes true brain I think
I want to order a whole bunch of it it
is delicious I mean it's it's very sweet
but like it was it's like you're
supposed to shoot it I mean it was it
was weird it was like sharp I always
feel better sharp that's how I can
describe it yeah I like that I like some
of the honest stuff they got that really
does there is pretty good uh-huh a lot
of the mushroom stuff yeah yeah shrimp
yeah
trash Panda says Anheuser-Busch has
awoken a sleeping giant this thing with
Dylan Mulvaney has very likely put a
stake through the heart of ESG and the
wef
No Joke Man I mean it's kind of crazy
this this wave is happening and the
media is desperate they're like no no
Target stock is not falling because of
this it's market conditions and I'm like
Walmart's up yeah what are you talking
about
yeah
Joseph Ray says while I'm listening to
this live stream at work through my
headphones my gen Z co-worker is
listening to Hassan's stream at the
exact same time that's America baby
yeah it's going to be really interesting
when like I don't know how how Hassan
maintains it to be completely honest
like he's a he's a very very wealthy
socialist you know and he is like
there's no real argument so I think the
only real issue is that there's General
personality fan base no Hassan is dumb
like he is he is the himbo he is pretty
that's why he's a big attractive looking
man he is not a smart guy him and Lance
like same level Lance from the Surfs
they it like I respect Lance for trying
he really did like he actually came with
notes and everything and it was really
funny how one example I can give when I
asked him why did why did he think so
many kids are coming out as trans he
holds up the left-handed thing yo I
wasn't arguing with him I literally
asked him what his thoughts were and
then I talked about endocrine disruptors
but all these leftists made videos where
they were like Lance owns Tim Poole
questioning trans kids or whatever and I
was like bro I wasn't questioning him I
was literally asking him what his
thoughts were I noticed they don't know
they don't know the difference between
men and women like what do you expect
there's a funny tweet uh Elon Musk I
think tweeted something and uh that
Angela what's her name El Camino or
whatever and she said something like
conservatives have a hard time
understanding the difference between sex
and gender and I at respond I was like
actually I think it's liberals who who
are having a hard time understanding the
difference oh yeah because like we
didn't make a female sporting events
because sometimes people wear dresses
yeah exactly that's gender yeah we're
talking about a distinction between sex
but they can't seem to figure that out
I'm starting to buy there's there's an
argument that there is no gender right
like that is that is relatively New
Concept if yeah that it's it's not
actually different from your from your
sex like they're so closely related that
to call them different things is wrong
dude the idea that if you wear a dress
you're a woman is absurd considering
people wear flowy robes in other
countries and their dudes like go go to
a Scottish guys we're gonna kill to be
like you must be a woman I used to
understand it like this so like my dog
is a female she is not a woman right
like and I was like well so that kind of
makes sense to me that a woman is
different than you know a female human
but I think in the context of humans
they're so closely related that I'm I'm
not so sure that I buy that argument or
so when Lance was on the show he
outlined it very very perfectly how
their ideology is literally insane when
he said that if a man has adult
relations with a small effeminate
looking man he is straight I'm like okay
wait what yes because his so they've
backed themselves into this corner with
their own broken ideology so here's what
starts they say trans women are women
therefore if and I asked him I was like
so if you're a straight if you're like a
male and you engage in relations with a
trans woman is that gay he says no of
course not because trans women are women
and I'm like okay but trans women are
biologically male they've got male parts
now because women it's like you you look
at how their body type is their their
skin their height all of these things
play a role I said okay so what if you
have a man who identifies as a man
and he's a feminate five foot two 120
pounds and another man who is six foot
tall and Burley decides to have
relations with that other man is that
gay and he goes no
wow but I'm like but they're both men
yeah he's like but he's a feminate and
then I think Ian asked like what if the
woman is like what if a guy has sex with
a woman who's like really big and
masculine is that again he goes yeah and
it's just like what
because there's no there's no logic to
what they're saying it's just like you
you know what they've done they got a
jigsaw puzzle in front of them and they
started mashing random pieces together
and they're just bashing them on the
table to make them fit right well and it
goes back to this observable reality
right like what you can observe is real
and what they're trying to do is control
language and control uh the way that we
associate with each other now right I
mean it's all comes down to control and
what they are forcing is our compliance
in this ideology it's just another just
facet of the total control ideology of
the left this is just one facet of it
and look like I said I mean a child when
they are born that that gender is not
determined it is observed right I mean
there are intrinsic immutable
characteristics of women right that's
just the way it is I would say their sex
is is observed when they're born but
gender I don't really understand I still
I learned about it or when I was young
gender's not a thing it was created in
like the 50s 1950s or something and the
problem is so look the left there
there's sex is observed did I say gender
gender yeah yeah yeah
so what what the left would consider
gender United States doesn't exist
outside of it
you if if they're saying that the social
constructs around the uh a person's
sexist gender it's different in
different countries so the problem would
be you get a Scottish kid from a
traditional Scottish family who for some
like let's just say the kid was wearing
a kilt comes here and they're gonna be
like that's a woman get him the surgery
he's like no they wear kilts like it's
not a skirt you might think it's a skirt
kids make jokes about it yeah and if
you're talking about other countries
think about this not just get outside of
the english-based language uh countries
like United Kingdom United States think
about Latin America or any of these
other places like Spain that speaks
Spanish right the entire language
is based around uh masculine and
feminine right you know so if you say
sir you know you're Senor if you're a
woman senorita right so a bit even every
object has essentially a masculine or
feminine
um uh word attached to it that's how the
entire language works yeah yeah l or La
yeah yes and French too yeah all right
let's read some more we got Trine 54 he
says screw the Eve 6 cover I'd love Tim
cast cover of Pink Floyd's Another Brick
in the Wall imagine Phil shredding that
chorus hey teachers oh yeah that
actually is a really good idea let's do
it leave those kids alone leave those
kids alone we should do it and then but
we should also do the 86 cover just to
make it mad
that song
maybe he hears to the night
one of the most notable songs of Our
Generation and I believe one of the best
of the 90s hands down it just came out
of nowhere man those guys have hit the
road too splash I think uh promise is is
like early 2000s pop punk treasure I
think here's to the night is
I I don't I don't know where I would put
on the list of the best songs of the top
songs of all time but I put it on the
list I'm not going to compare it to
another brick in the wall or Time by
Pink Floyd or anything I think that'd be
silly it's like it's not the lord of
rings Lord of the Rings like which is an
epic but it's it's up there in one of
those you know songs like you you like
The Mummy two or something you know the
song here tonight right like I don't not
have you played it I would you played it
for me before but I didn't hear it it's
a good one it's a good one and then they
also have
um what I said uh yeah promise here's
the Knight and they have a bunch of
other ones
um what's that what's that one uh well
curtain is good that was that was later
I would love to do a cover of any one of
these but I got to be honest the reason
I won't is because I think this this
this guy Max is probably too ideological
to allow some things to succeed and
you'd run into him just filing dmcas or
something for for political points which
is like hey it's unfortunate unless the
cover is really good then he's gonna be
jamming along nah nah he'll get a bunch
of people tweeting at him being like
look what he's doing and then he'll beg
though okay I'll take it down I mean if
you do it with respect for the song I it
might transcend politics it's worth
trying if you really like it it will it
will transcend transcend politics for
the listeners it will not transcend
politics for Max we need that in the
world right now the Battle of the Bands
has returned get ready oh Trump's having
a rally on Tuesday apparently according
to truth social where Trump posted of
things calling for a rally or something
where is it uh Miami it's an all hands
on deck Trump document hoax rally
um in Miami a pair only on Tuesday
hopefully they bring the boat song Back
do you remember the Trump Spanish song
Spanish language yeah yeah that was
amazing that song was awesome I just
want to say this everybody
be careful because you all know how
January 6 went down
you might you might be walking down the
street and then they're going to be like
20 minutes ago there was a barrier there
and now you're now you're violating
Federal property so
you got to be peaceful but beyond that
you have to like have your lawyer at
your side at all times advising you on
what to do there were a lot of people on
January 6 who had no idea what was going
on and watched people walking into a
building as police fanned them in and
those people are now sitting in jail
so keep that in mind
all right Logan Culver says Phil with
massive 20s tonight
thank you massive 20s yeah when you
asked elad to stop interrupting you I
was like this is genuine discourse this
is we need more of this
I got love for a lot
it's mutual we just fired up I'm not I'm
not your buddy guy says I want to give a
shout out to a great documentary
everyone should watch called the Great
Awakening please help share with your
friends and family we have a chance to
stop this evil
uh but that window for the West is
closing I don't know what that
documentary is but thanks for the Super
Chat
I don't know is that a q thing or
something
don't know by Jeffrey Morrison
all right let's grab some more Super
chats there was one that I wanted to
read because someone was making a point
of something
uh well this one sounds good what is
this domestic Torah says shout out to
Joshua from Arkansas My ATT rep from
this afternoon Tim cast was the medium
which brought two strangers together to
discuss politics while waiting on hold
nice by the way sorry to cancel my line
man
that was a good one nice
lunderwear says I'm not a coffee drinker
but since you went with with focus with
Mr bocus I'm gonna buy the crap out of
that when it comes out all right yep
yeah it's all it's all coming I think
but first I think we have unwoke sleepy
Joe and Mr boca's pumpkin spice
experience
we want to keep the pump pumpkin spice
and stocky around because it makes no
sense not to but everyone does so we're
going to capture the market sleepy Joe
decaf is that the that's right that's
gotta be a decaf and unwelcome as well
yeah okay there's no waking him
Spencer Jones says love the guest
tonight elad love your work Ian keep it
weird okay the first I was gonna say
this earlier the first time we ever
talked about BlackRock vanguarden State
treat State Street Ian's the one who
brought it up I think it was out I think
it was Alex Jones in his episode but I I
started hitting it really hard right
away when I heard about it and it was uh
I think yeah yeah Vanguard was the first
one I I heard of you know I'm glad you
guys are been talking about it I mean
like when I was when I divested from
them two years ago people are like what
the hell are you talking about like what
what is this and you know here we are
now it is it has been going on for so
long too like most people don't realize
how long they've been doing this uh or
working on this project the the ESG
project I I think it's been going on for
longer than a decade it's about 20 years
I want to remember in 2012 is when I
think as when I it sparked my radar so
it actually ESG kind of the investment
strategy was started actually by a
bureaucrat in the United Nations yeah
and that's where it originally uh took
hold and of course here we are now all
those all those alliances that they have
like the Net Zero asset managers
Alliance it's run by the U.N so these
are all un organizations all right we
got self-made woman saying two things
one your reporter is rolling out of ones
two pride month is cringe captured and
regulated ideological narratives by
governing Elites
all right
collisionokov says shout out to Shane
Cashman he had a masterful interview
with Alex Jones the other day Alex was
so happy this is so happy in the
interviews it's actually a really funny
story because uh Shane was going to
interview Alex and we were like trying
to track Alex down because he's so busy
and like Alex was like yeah definitely
let's do this we'll have to find a time
and then we were like we don't know if
we can figure out where he's going to be
because he's getting bounced around and
called all these different things
and I'm talking to Shane I'm like Shane
look man you know Alex is very very busy
it'd be really cool if we were able to
get but if you can't do it you can do it
he's like yeah and then like the next
day it's like Shane Cashman on Infowars
and I was like oh I guess it worked out
and you guys can follow Shane Cashman on
Instagram he's got Clips up from the
show it's at Shane Cashman
where are we at
flying failure says Mr Moore we spoke
after I called into your office
concerning West Virginia financials are
you concerned with the companies like
Citadel who post record earnings but
hold billions in the hole with assets
yet to be purchased
yeah certainly I'd say it is concerning
uh it is concerning what was the what
was the commenter's name this is flying
failure ah okay well then I don't
remember I remember talking on failure
but no certainly concerning
Jason Gardner says Tim stop saying LGBT
is using God's covenant God's rainbow is
seven colors and LGBT is six not the
same it's the devil's rainbow no no you
misunderstand I said they're
appropriating God's covenant they are
trying to take the general concept of
rainbow for themselves and taking it
away from Christians I understand God's
covenant is different but that would be
like someone taking the American flag
changing it to Pride colors and waving
it around and you being like nah it's a
totally different flag like no they're
they're taking the American flag and
they do this
I told Sheamus I'm like I'm Christians
should absolutely take the rainbow like
and use it Fly it's God's covenant have
you seen it out outside of a lot of
churches so maybe they already are oh
yeah yeah
seriously I think those are mostly
Episcopalian yeah I don't know enough
about the denominator is there was there
a joke no those are the ones that are
generally come flying it yeah
all right what do we got let me see uh
Red Line says Tim throwing money at you
gaze against groomers and Scott Nugent
hosting a peaceful protest at St Louis
Pride Saturday the 24th uh people even
LGBT are tired of kids seeing lewd crap
too and we're speaking out but antifa
found out would greatly appreciate if
you helped signal boost the thing well I
read your super chat you know so there
you go what city was that in
specifically St Louis St Louis the thing
that people are are fed up with always
be peaceful is the queer Theory right
like most people have got were were
comfortable or most people are
comfortable with gay people with with
homosexuals lesbians and I think that
our society will have very little
problem assimilating so that we're
making making concessions for Trans
people but what we can't do is allow a
in a an ideology that is intentionally
subversive to undermine the structure of
our society we are a liberal Society
queer theory is based on authoritarian
leftist authoritarianism and that's the
problem the problem is not that there
are gay people or that there are
lesbians or that there are even trans
people our society can easily handle all
of that stuff with minimal actual
changes in your in everyone's day-to-day
life it's the communism it's the
communism like 100 people
in this sphere love Blair white
the issue is the communism the the the
the American traditional and and
Classical liberalism works but
Communists are trying to subvert and
destroy it and it's not are you not
saying that like hate and ignore the
theory of queerness when you say queer
Theory it's actual native tactic is that
what the queer theory is based on the
idea that there is no that there should
be no gender there are gender
abolitionists
um and I I ca I don't want to try to get
too uh too deep in explaining queer
Theory because I'm not well versed
enough and to explain it to someone I
can I can understand I can identify it
but for me to articulate it properly I
would be I would probably do it
disservice so and we've got one more
Super Chat Retro Retro Retro how do you
pronounce this retrocalypse there you go
says there are two Sexes zero genders
and infinite personalities I heard that
from billboard Chris love you all and
with that my friends smash the like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends become a
member at timcast.com to support our
work directly and all you can also buy
our coffee at casper.com you can follow
the show at timcastirl you can follow me
personally at timcast Riley do you want
to shout anything out yeah uh Riley
Moore you can follow me at rileymorewv
on Twitter Facebook Instagram uh those
are my campaign accounts running for
congress in West Virginia second
congressional district check it out love
to have some support thanks Riley thank
you so much for coming on everybody I am
Ahad aliyahu you can find me under that
name and I do all of my reporting
alongside other great reporters on
timcast news um on Twitter so make sure
you follow us at timcast news on Twitter
thanks for having me on
I am philibonti I am Phil that remains
on Twitter I am Phil that remains
official on Instagram the band is All
That Remains were available on Spotify
Apple music uh Amazon music the old
YouTube here
there you go I mean Crossing you guys
thanks for keeping me honest in the chat
in the comments and the video responses
and everything it's great do Riley
awesome man thanks for bringing the
economics thanks I love talking about
that stuff so I hope we get to do that
again we could do this again yeah I'd
love to anytime rolls down the road man
awesome awesome I look forward to
working with we're gonna skate tomorrow
so that's gonna be fun yeah we're gonna
skate tomorrow so that'll be fun Kellen
PDL yeah how hilarious sorry like you me
and Richie went to uh like Freedom Plaza
in DC these people would lose their
minds uh they'd be pretty bummed you
know Richie too thanks for hanging out
yeah I love that guy what's up Richie uh
yeah you guys should do it that would be
awesome follow me at Kellen PDL it's
good hanging out with you guys tonight
all right everybody we will see you all
in the clips we put up throughout the
weekend and then we'll be back Monday
thanks for hanging out